there is something going on with this
2024 presidential primary that should
interest political scientists
psychologists
sociologists it it's unbelievable the
dynamic that is developed between Nikki
Haley who announced her candidacy on
Tuesday against Donald Trump and Trump
himself Trump very quickly jumping out
and attacking Nikki Haley as terrible at
her job Nikki Haley not attacking Trump
in fact not even drawing any
distinctions and yesterday morning she
appeared on Fox and Friends she's been
going around saying we need a cognitive
test for politicians over age 75. now
she mostly means it because of Biden but
she's argued the real advantage to her
over Trump is she's from a new
generation which means she's younger so
in some sense Trump being 76 and Nikki
saying if you're 75 or older you should
take a cognitive test it also applies to
Trump so the Fox and Friends crew asks
Nikki Haley about it and says well how
would Trump do on that test because he's
also of that age Nikki doesn't take the
bait refusing to criticize Donald Trump
how would Donald Trump do on the
competency test if uh at 76 years old
no reason to think he wouldn't do well
this time he identified the tiger it was
great but I do think we need it and it's
across the board I don't think it's for
president I think you look at Congress
look at all the members of Congress you
have to start doing this for elected
officials when people send someone to
Washington they need to know they're at
the top of their game that's why I think
those competency tests are important we
can't have someone like Joe Biden who's
asleep at the wheel and have China
sitting there threatening us and US
wondering if he actually knows what's
going on this is good for America to do
competency tests this isn't about one
person yeah so refusing to criticize
Donald Trump this is the funniest sort
of dance that's taking place here do I
criticize Trump don't I well I am
running against them but I also don't
want to go against them too hard and
maybe she's actually running fibby
Trump's VP that's another thing that
occurred to me this is really a campaign
so that she runs a campaign doesn't
insult Trump and then if she does well
enough maybe Trump invites her to be his
running mate I don't know this campaign
is palpably palpable you could just feel
it it's thick it's going nowhere
um in another moment during the same
interview she said
Donald Trump is my friend yeah it's not
in exactly that way take a listen to
this when you flip around
to answer that yeah
well first of all president Trump is my
friend I was honored to work with him in
the administration I thought he was the
right president at the right time and
that remains to be the truth we had a
great conversation I told him that I was
doing this because I thought it was time
for a new generation I thought we needed
to leave the staff I told him you're too
old and we needed to move forward so
I I just don't even know where to start
first of all
is it possible
that Trump actually does
want Nikki Haley to run it is possible
and I keep going back to the same reason
why when you look at 2024 Republican
primary polling when it's Trump versus
DeSantis head-to-head DeSantis does way
better and sometimes is actually winning
when you have a poll that it's do you
want Trump or DeSantis or Pence or Don
Jr or Mike Pompeo or Nikki Haley or
Roger Stone or Alex Jones who have the
more people you stuff into the poll
the better Trump does because a lot of
those other choices take away more from
DeSantis than they do from Trump right
now so one could make the argument Trump
wants as many people as possible to run
because it hurts DeSantis and it helps
him that's a possibility secondly
is there any shot that Nikki Haley wins
this nomination if she refuses to go
head-on and criticize Trump and by
criticize I don't even mean insult I
just mean draw some policy distinctions
right do something to show other than
just being young and a minority and a
woman which is the identity politics
that Nikki played at her first rally
which we covered yesterday which took
place Wednesday
you have no chance and the same applies
to Ron DeSantis but differently with Ron
DeSantis I think DeSantis if he does Run
for the nomination has to abandon taking
the high road because it's just not what
Republican voters seem to want but with
Nikki Haley's campaign if all you're
going to say is Trump is my friend and
you're not going to criticize him in
terms of policy you're not going to
suggest yeah the cognitive test is for
Trump too because he might be
you're going absolutely nowhere there's
just no way and if her intention is
really just to be the VP rather than uh
be the nominee then maybe this is the
right approach it's just not clear what
she's thinking we should figure out
is she coming up with these ideas or are
these the ideas of her advisors is she
waiting to transition in the here's what
what is different about me I don't know
the answer but this is already a
completely insane primary we will have
the clips I played for you here
on our YouTube channel youtube.com slash
the David Pacman show and this clip will
be dubbed into Spanish and available on
the Spanish YouTube channel which you
can find at davidpackman.com
Spanish check it out
did you know that every year 30 million
trees are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
stocks which keep growing forever no
trees are cut down it's shipped right to
your door in plastic free packaging it's
fluffy it's soft like regular toilet
paper you're not making any quality
sacrifice and for every box you buy real
paper donates to reforestation efforts
Across America through their partnership
with one tree planted so instead of the
toilet paper you're currently buying
which cuts down trees and wastes plastic
use real paper actively helping the
planet you can set up a recurring
subscription so you're always stocked or
do a one-time purchase the average
American uses 50 pounds of toilet paper
or more every year make the easy switch
to real paper you'll get 30 off your
first order plus free shipping go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below